في قرار هو الاول من نوعه اصدرت وزاره
الرياضه قرارا بتكليف حنان القرشي رئيسا
لنادي وجه الرياضي بالطائف ذلك بعد حلم
مجلس اداره النادي واكد حساب نادي عبر
تويتر انه جرى تكليف حنان القرشي برئاسه
مجلس اداره نادي ويد وترشيح اعضاء المجلس
المؤقت هذا وشارك النادي في دوري الامير
محمد بن سلمان للدرجه الاولى في العام
بعد ان صعد من انديه الدرجه الثالثه ثم
صعد الى انديه الدرجه الثانيه ومنها الى
الاولى
تنضم الينا من الطائف رئيسه نادي ويتش
حنان القرشي حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض الف مبروك اولا اول
امراه سعوديه تراس نادي رياضي وخليني اسال
اولا عن اللي دفعك للقبول بهذا التكليف
هذا المنصب وهذه الاولويه انجاز التعبير
اولا يا هلا ويا مرحبا وحياكم جميعا
الله يبارك فيك ان شاء الله
والله شوف اولا واخيرا كل دوافعنا هي تظل
هي حب لهذا البلد المعطى حب لقيادتنا
الجميله حب للنجاح حب للرياضه
حب انه يكون في كل مجالات ببلد هذا اللي
يحتاج منه لهذا الوقفه وهذا النجاحات وهذا
العطاء
فلو سالتني هذا السؤال يكون هناك الكثير
من الكلمات التي تعبر عن هذا الشيء ممتاز
على مستوى الرياضي
يعني ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمينه تقدمينه
لنادي وجه انت وباقي اعضاء مجلس الاداره
اللي طبعا يكتمل مجلس الاداره خلال الايام
القادمه لكن اسال عن الاهداف الان اللي
قدام عينيك المجال الرياضي الرياضي مجال
جميل وفي نفس الوقت هو صعب يحتاج الكثير
من الاداره الحكيمه من الامور الماليه
الجيده التي تدعم وترفعوا حكومتنا ما قصرت
ولاه الامر ما قصروا علينا دعم سخيف جدا
لكن نسال الله التوفيق والسداد بالاداره
الجيده بالاعضاء الجيدين لكي نحقق النجاح
المامول والمطمح له باذن الله ممتاز مش
اهم الاهداف اليوم على خارطه حنان قرشي في
رئاستها والله باذن الله باذن الله حاعمل
جاهده اننا نوصل للدرجه الاولى لدور
الممتاز لروشن طموح كبير لكن باذن الله
نحاول نوصله بوقفه اهالي الط طيبين
الكرماء المعطائيين سمو المحافظ
دولتنا بقيادتنا ما قصرت معانا وان شاء
الله النجاح باذن الله يكون قريب انت
عارفه انه المجال الرياضي مجال يمكن شوي
صعب في التعامل في الضغوطات ايضا بشكل
بشكل كبير ويمكن انت شفتي خلال المواسم
اللي راحت كل ما زادت حده التنافس والتحدي
في الموسم الاعلام ايضا حتى كذا يجوز مهم
كبير من هالمساله هل انت مستعده لهذه
المغامره
والله بلدنا يستحق الا يستحق هذا البلد
لمن غامر لمن غامر عشانه انا انا اسالك
هذه المغامره نقول يا رب نقول يا رب الله
معنا والتوفيق بيد رب العالمين
اهي محاوله للنجاح النجاحنا في الخير ان
شاء الله
لنا وللجميع وانت فشلنا نقول في هذا من
انفسنا وليس من الاخرين يعني في النهايه
هو اجتهاد اتمنى اتمنى فعلا اني انا احقق
لان هو موجود في الدوري الدرجه الثانيه
نادي
يحتاج صفقات كثيره يحتاج اللاعبين ايضا
يعني على على قدر كبير من خلينا نقول
المهاره وعلى قدر ايضا كبير حتى من
المسؤوليه وهذه كلها تحتاج للملائه ماليه
اللي هي هذه موجوده اليوم في نادي ويتش
موجود عند حنان القرشي او كيف حتوفره
ليست موجوده بمعنى موجوده ولكن موجود اللي
ان شاء الله يساعد نحتاج الكثير
بنحاول نوجد هذا الكثير
على قدر ما نستطيع
الامل موجود يظل الامل موجود على ايجاد
مصادر ماليه للنادي باذن الله احنا شغالين
على هذا المكتب باذن الله احنا شغالين على
هذا النقطه ويدوب يعني الموضوع ما حصل له
يومين لكن نحاول نجتهد ونلحق على قولتهم
اللي نقدر نلحق عليه يا رب تعدين هم
يكونوا في دوري الدرجه الاولى ان شاء الله
يا رب باذن الله باذن الله حامل جاهده
انكم في الدوري الدرجه الاولى بمشيئه
حيكون في عظام الاداره سيدات
باذن الله هذه المره انا حريصه جدا
وحتكوني حريصه برضو على الرياضات النسائيه
في نادي وتفعيلها وتكون اكثر يعني والله
انا مسبقا كنت احد الاعضاء الموجودين
بالنادي هنائبه الرئيس والرئيس التنفيذي
برضو للنادي
فتقريبا الى حد ما كل همي واهتمامي هي كره
القدم حاليا الالعاب المختلفه ثانيا حريصه
جدا على مجال السيدات واني انا ارتقي فيه
بلدنا تستاهل تستاهلي
بالتوفيق ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك من
الطائف رئيسه
شكرا لكم جميعا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات